I'm Gabriel Carter Ella whiskey nerd  adventure brand ambassador for doers  John doer started the company in 1846 by  the time his son Tommy joined the  company doers was well known in all over  the UK but it was thanks to Tommy doers  became a global brand tommy was very  smart and figuring out a way to travel  world and he had nothing but a bag full  of whiskey with them you know in some  countries in his book he wrote by ramble  around the globe traveled by camel and  in two years time Tommy visited 26  different countries doers became one of  the most popular scotches in the world  we absolutely appreciate the fact that  we make the whiskey still double aging  our doers 12 year old 15 year old 18 do  our signature risky and that's what we  think about won't talk about doers  whiskey when I show up to a holiday  party I wanna bring a gift that's  memorable when I bring a bottle of  Dewar's 12 not just sharing a great  glass of whiskey I'm also sharing great  stories too